russian forces are set to continue their
offensive in eastern ukraine after
claiming victory in lessee chance on
sunday ukraine's military withdrew from
the strategically important city meaning
the luhansk region is now entirely under
russian control ukraine is now braced
for further attacks against the city of
slovyansk as russian forces continue to
push westwards
russia is expected to attempt to take
control of donetsk
that along with
luhansk makes up the wider donbass
region ukraine's president zielenski
says his country will recover the lost
territory
now yuri sack is an adviser to the
ukrainian defense minister i asked him
about the significance of the loss of
lissy chansk
for ukraine and for ukrainian armed
forces
temporary loss of any city no matter how
big or small
a temporary loss of every meter of
territory is significant and this is why
we
every time when we have to temporarily
leave certain areas or certain cities
we insist that we will be back
and our president says that the
ukrainian armed forces are committed to
the occupied all the temporarily
occupied territories
but of course lisa chance is
you know the last large city in luhansk
oblast
but what has to be noted is that
today uh ukrainian armed forces are
still in luran's region so even though
it is a very small part of mugan's
region but according to the reports of
the local authorities
ukrainian armed forces are still there
on a small part of land right
and this of course comes with the loss
of um uh of mario poland significant
swathes of of eastern ukraine
is this war
moving
russia's way
we don't believe this war moving
russia's way because there are other
areas of uh ukraine which are
temporarily occupied by these war
criminals
where ukrainian armed forces are
actually gaining ground and
retaking certain areas this is the south
of ukraine the capsule region this is
area around kharkiv the second second
largest city in ukraine so
this is a war it's a very dynamic war
and of course in those areas where
russians have focused and concentrated
all of their firepower firing tens of
thousands of artillery shells a day of
course it is it makes sense for
ukrainian armed forces because we value
human life to retreat temporarily but in
other areas we are already
counter-attacking and providing we
receive more heavy weaponry soon we will
be able to do it even more efficiently
i think you bring us on to my next
question which was you talk about these
losses as being temporary how do you
reverse them
you reverse them by
receiving sufficient number of heavy
artillery
multi-launch rocket systems tanks
aircraft air defense systems anti-rocket
systems everything that our
international partners have committed to
provide us with and you do it militarily
so you you you you've been singing the
same song if i can put it that way for
for some months now that bring us uh uh
more uh heavy weaponry and this despite
promises from the likes of the united
states uh united kingdom
and germany to do just that
are they just not arriving quick enough
for you
some of the heavy weaponry that we have
been promised
by the united states
by germany by the uk has already arrived
in ukraine and is efficiently being used
on the front lines and we are very
grateful to our international partners
all of those who have gathered at
ramstein at nato summit recently and
they have committed themselves
wholeheartedly to support ukraine
militarily for as long as it takes but
of course
you know us and
on the battlefield we need we understand
that we need more heavy weaponry and we
need it faster and we hope that our
partners will find ways to deliver us
this
vital military assistance sooner rather
than later
and so now as russia
secures uh its hold on the the east of
ukraine where do you expect it to turn
its uh its firepower next what do you
expect it's its next target to be
well first of all russia has not yet
established its hold on the east of
ukraine because there's still donetsk
region and there are cities such as
slavyansk they've been mentioned in your
report earlier there is a city of
kramatorsk and there are very capable
highly motivated and professional
ukrainian armed forces which are located
there and they will continue resistance
and actually these cities the slovakian
cremators are most likely to be the next
major
the next major objective military
objective of the russian aggressor but
the major the key overarching military
objective of the aggressor has always
been to encircle ukrainian armed forces
in the east of ukraine and destroy them
and this has not happened this has not
happened because even from listed chance
ukrainian armed forces have been able to
retreat without losses so from that
perspective we understand where the next
target will be but we also understand
that we are doing everything we can in
terms of tactics and maneuvers to ensure
that we incur as much losses on our
enemy as possible and at the same time
we sustain as fewer losses as possible
right so clearly from the ukrainian side
this ain't over yet yuri sack
advises to the ukrainian defense
ministry thank you so much for joining
us
thank you so much for inviting me
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
says rebuilding the country will be a
colossal job so let's take a closer look
at the scale of the damage done so far
more than a hundred hospitals have been
destroyed damage to civilian
infrastructures running at more than an
estimated four and a half billion pounds
billion euros per week
thousands of kilometers of roads have
been wrecked and hundreds of bridges
blown up ukrainian officials put total
economic losses from this war at more
than 500 billion euros
ukrainian officials and international
leaders have begun a two-day conference
in the swiss city of lugano and to come
up with a plan to fund ukraine's
reconstruction after russia's
devastating war
timothy uh malavanov is an economic
adviser to president vladimir zelinsky
he's a former ukrainian economy minister
and he's also president of the kiev
school of economics he joins us from
those reconstruction talks welcome to dw
um what does uh key what does um
ukraine hope to get from these talks
one
something actionable a platform or a
mechanism of coordination of all
activities and aid around ukraine
something which will streamline the
process
be a sense of urgency in the minds of
people that funding is needed and this
c is
a
number you know a number a common
knowledge number an agreed upon number
of how much funds are needed and for
what purposes okay so and as i
understand it the the the plan for
today's meeting is not to actually raise
those funds to but to effectively look
at how they would be used how ukraine
would be rebuilt
that is correct uh there is overall
understanding that funds are needed and
the partners are very sympathetic uh
there are a lot of questions about the
priorities mechanisms architecture
transparency governance corruption you
know all those issues have to be
addressed and they have to be addressed
now and this is what the conference is
about and
many would look at this and say well
isn't it too soon to be talking about
reconstruction while bombs are still
dropping while a war is still raging
that's exactly one of the questions
which was discussed today heads on you
know uh isn't it too early let's wait
until after the war and the government
comes forward
with a two different
approaches or two different numbers one
is what's needed now to maintain the
economy and they call it rapid recovery
and the number is about 65 billion
dollars and that includes hospitals
schools bridges which need to be
recovered now for the economy to
continue to operate and then there is a
number of what happens after the war
right and let's
we'll continue to focus on after the war
because there's an intriguing question
here um which which is well
doesn't it rather depend on who wins and
what a win
looks like because
to put it simply
is this plan likely to happen is this
are the funds likely to flow
if russia is in charge of ukraine
absolutely this is the question all of
this is predicated on victory and uh a
number of speakers today at the
conference made it crystal clear that we
need to support ukraine now both
financially in terms of weapons uh so
that their construction a is cheaper b
makes sense at all of course uh if
weapons are not forced coming uh we
might be in a situation there's not much
to recover right so you're absolutely
correct
right so
the the the funds and the plan that
depends up presumably then just looking
at what victory might look like would
that depend on russia giving up
territory that it has taken
well you know russia is not going to
give up anything so it has to be taken
away from russia
or there should be you know they're
essentially a couple of uh
outcomes one can think of one is uh
ukraine will be able with help of
international partners and friends to
recover territories or ukraine won't be
able uh immediately to recover this
territories uh but some will be and the
front lines will stabilize somewhere and
this was a discussion too what happens
if the front lines stabilize for a while
and the
war becomes protracted prolonged how
should we go about this and so there are
multiple scenarios
you you mentioned um corruption was was
one of the things that that
will come up at this conference because
of course before russia invaded there
were widespread concerns about a
corruption in ukraine reconstruction is
going to mean
billions and billions of euros are
flowing into and out of the country do
you accept that there that there will be
continuing uh concern amongst uh
potential
accreditors and investors about where
and how this money is accounted for
there are two concerns one is corruption
within ukraine and the second concern is
lobbyism and getting the preferred
contractors which are politically
connected to different donors uh and the
the first concern undermines the
transparency and trust into the effort
and the second concern just makes their
construction effort very very expensive
so both have to be addressed and for
that uh there are been multiple
proposals what kind of governance
mechanisms can address them uh the
important aspect is to understand that
these issues are concentrated in the
area of procurement first of all so
making procurement uh very clear very
specific very transparent will help
and will go a long way thank you so much
for outlining that so clearly uh timothy
uh
milivanov economic advisers to ukrainian
president uh vladimir zelenki thank you